use the tables of future values of $1 to
find a future values all be reduced
we'll just do one we just walk through
it okay so if we have two and a half
thousand dollars the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm gonna write future
values equals two and a half thousand
dollars now you're going to create the
idea of saying it to some of you last
week this certainly seen characters to
me when I started having a bank account
turn around and dollars put into a
single bank account but here is exactly
the same and $2,500 sorry 2500 separate
one dollar bank accounts can I repeat
that again because it's weird putting
this amount of money in one bank account
versus splitting it into lots and lots
of tiny little making up they all earn
exactly the same amount of interest they
all behave the same way putting them in
a big lot doesn't make them gain more
interests faster or anything like that
okay so I can treat this $2,500 just
like two thousand five hundred
individual dollars right and then work
out each of their future values okay so
let's have a look at this specific
future value they want five years six
percent per annum okay so when you have
a look at five years you're counting
down the rows right can you look at your
have you got your table then right so
count down to the fifth one you've
invested $2,000 every year and then
you're going to have to count to the
right to 6% okay so in fact I'm gonna
try and do this we're going to use the
top table right do you see why I'm going
to use the top table below why the top
table because when you think about the
time scale and the fact they've given
you interest per annum you might as well
I mean look at the numbers didn't say it
wasn't 6% registered yet so that's where
I'm going to be the bottom table is not
as useful to me okay so bear with me I'm
going to I'm actually going to suggest
that if you are see this in an exam and
you get this table and frequently you
get this physical table one of the
reasons we give you the actual paper so
you can write on it is so that you can
show you're working on the table believe
it or not sorry you think that you
believe it or not even without any
working on the board on your piece of
paper it's a digital photo you can
actually get a mug for doing this
what would you say five years five years
is yeah there's five years and six
percent B is here so I'm going to do
this at lunch is HSC without doing
anything for to mark question that got
one luck because why
think about it what have you
demonstrated if you can do that at a
minimum you can identify what on this is
going on here that these are the
important piece of information it
doesn't get you for last I donated the
questions yet but at least you know
where to call the table okay pin it
already again what am I going to do with
that insufficient here are you going to
have to find that works I'm going to
multiply because this is what happens to
$1 well I have 2500 of these right so
I'm just going to multiply that one what
does it say five four three three three
yeah okay so just as you write that down
and also be sure you calculate ISM
excuse me evaluate that you can see
immediately there's a teeny little
problem which is that you know we've got
four decimal places that's a
presentation about accuracy right but
this amount gets bigger and bigger and
bigger you're going to resolve
desolation that kind of thing so this
method is not perfect but it's certainly
a lot more efficient than having to
multiply through and do this five rows
of working and we add to that variable
every single year like just look at the
what you have to do you realize nothing
much at all if someone already
multiplied to about 2500 for 10,000 in
ninety two dollars and seventy five
cents fourteen thousand ninety two and
seventy five cents okay yeah here's a
tricky beam um I've always encouraged
you to do sense checks and I still do
when you look at another doesn't make
sense if tricky to do sense checks with
big though because when you look at this
it just seems crazy when you think about
this amount of money and what it will
become the integral short period of time
okay so we've done the first thing let's
come back to the question what are we
being asked now that's part one what
part to calculate the amount of interest
earned on each investment okay so I'm
trying to compare or rather contrast the
amount that I'm putting in that I'm
reinvesting every year versus how much
the actual percentage is doing right so
how many times did I put two thousand
dollars into this maybe it happened five
times right so I'm going to take
interest equals if that future value
which includes my five lakhs of money
and their interest so I'm going to take
away my lots of money does that make
sense
you told me or just five times that I
put in two and a half thousand dollars
right so if I take out my share of
things what I actually put in manually
in what get left in the uterus is
delicate so this is a quarter you need
to take away one now sorry 12,500 yeah I
don't know what that is one thousand
five hundred things that are in yeah one
590 again
so over the course of those five years
this is the amount that actually had
nothing to do with me just putting one
here this is what came from the sixty
second okay is the question like
actually mean calculate the amount of
interest earned on each investor what
that means is like we put our money into
this annuity in the hope that okay like
it's not just going to sit there and
just write it's actually going to
increase in size so the question is how
much did is increase how much bang for
our buck are we getting out of this
investment and this is how much we
actually gained as opposed to if I've
taken my lots of money and just let them
underneath my bed in cash right it would
have just stayed $12,500 because I kept
their investing it it turns into that
which means I gain because I don't
despair because if you did not if you
just put you in the top row to the
beginning which is not in doing it's
just a bank account there would be 2500
R times 1 plus 0.4 1.06 ^ 5 right which
would be our disability is pretty tiny
right like this is just the first one
that sits in there and we wait for six
use okay but we didn't we didn't wait
clearly but we kept on putting more in
and that's what we take out okay so once
it's like what times in this 2500
writers bribe what does that give you
what that means is so the duration of
time that you had this annuity nearly
five years every year and have I really
done some it and you'll mean you can put
it in that 2500 okay so what that looks
like is for example when you have a
salary like I went for the government
they're obliged to put money into my
superannuation and I can't touch it
right like it's not part of my salary so
if you ever look up a job advert right
it'll say your salary is this much per
annum plus
graduation done it up the government is
the government required employers to do
that okay so this amount of money keeps
going in year after year and hopefully
by the end it's grown because
investments have been positive all the
kind of things for financial crisis are
just not with me okay